welcome everyone to law and crime daily
I'm Brian buckmeyer a Florida courtroom
once again finds itself hosting a murder
trial tied to a rap artist this time ynw
Melly is the accused Monday was day one
in the double murder trial Mellie whose
given name is Jamel demons is accused of
killing two men he called his friends in
October of 2018 melly's best friend
Cortland Henry showed up at a Miami
Hospital claiming his friends were
caught in a drive-by shooting and were
bleeding out in his car Anthony Williams
and Christopher Thomas had multiple
gunshot wounds and were pronounced dead
Henry told officers they were shot out
while leaving a recording studio but
when police got there they say there was
no evidence that a drive-by had occurred
investigators determined the victims
were shot by someone in the car and
surveillance showed four men inside
including Melly police arrested Mellie
and Henry on two counts of first-degree
murder each they are being tried
separately have both pled not guilty
during opening statements the
prosecution pointed out melly's
popularity on social media may actually
be his undoing
on the Instagram
because the defendant had a moderate
social media following at the time of
these events
reaching out to him
fans some friends some Associates
you'll see on October 26th after about 8
A.M in the morning Eastern Time
multiple messages are coming in
messages are coming in from individuals
checking to see if he's okay
if he's been injured in this drive-by
if it's true that Anthony Williams who's
also sometimes referred to as sap and
Chris Thomas who is referred to as juvie
are really dead
one individual and specifically
sends out and I want to quote the
message exactly that you will hear
and says
right after this
yo homie
you good
let me know something
and so ladies and gentlemen this is
where context matters
what does that mean
if you work at Google
and you say my whole floor is coming
that's a good thing
if you work at Broward General Hospital
and you say my whole floor is coding
that is a bad thing
context around the messages matters
so in the context of this message
this individual is reaching out
asking if Mr demons is good after he's
been tagged in multiple social media
posts about this drive through
this shooting
and Mr demons responds very sustainably
I did that
ladies and gentlemen at the conclusion
of the evidence the state is confident
that you will find the defendant guilty
discharge of the first degree murder of
Christopher Thomas and Anthony Williams
all right I want to bring in my co-host
former trial Attorney Terry Austin and
our special guest former homicide
prosecutor Bernardo villalona Bernardo
sometimes it's not the crime but the
cover-up that gets it offended in hot
water how damn damaging is the defense
that this investigation occurred and
they tried to make it look like a
drive-by shooting but it actually wasn't
so for the prosecution this is one of
the strongest piece of evidence that
they are using so in a prosecution where
you're talking about someone giving up a
false information or a false lie or a
false narrative and you can prove that
that is an argument for the prosecution
to say wait the reason that they're
lying the reason that they came up with
that lie is because they're trying to
cover up the truth and that truth is
that the person actually committed the
crime so the cover-up sometimes is worse
than the crime itself yeah Terry what do
you think will be the most important or
for lack of a better term The Smoking
Gun in this case well there's no doubt
forensics is the issue here we need to
know whether or not those bullets came
from outside the car into the car or
they came from inside the car so they're
gonna both sides I think need to have
forensic evidence now clearly the
defense does not have to do that but if
they do it I think that's what the issue
will be and I think that's what the jury
is going to focus on so I also
definitely think that you're going to
have to see what those hands were like
whether or not there was gun residue and
whose hand had the gun residue if
there's gun residue then you know that
some of those defendants might have
actually pulled the trigger so I think
it's going to be forensics forensic
forensics yeah I'm curious to see
whether or not the defense goes with
this whole drive by Theory or abandons
it for something else well we'll see as
the case continues still had a long
crime daily our coverage of ynw melly's
murder trial continues
they have no reason for why he would do
this
because there is no reason
we're breaking down the defense's
opening statement next
welcome back to lawn crime daily ynw
Melly a young Florida rapper whose given
name is Jamal demons is on trial for
allegedly shooting two men inside a car
where they bled out Christopher Thomas
and Anthony Williams were good friends
with Melly and another man Cortland
Henry they're believed to have all been
in the same car in 2018 when Thomas and
Williams were shot prosecutors say
Mellie and Henry try to make it seem
like a drive-by shooting during his
opening statement melly's offense
attorneys say it makes no sense for him
to kill his friends
prosecutors are given
great power
endless resources
form their mission of pursuing Justice
but that's not what occurred here
what they will bring you is a case
that is riddled
with Reasonable Doubt
that is founded on an incompetent and
incomplete investigation
and the exercise of poor Judgment at
every turn
State cannot prove Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt the allegations that they have
made
and there is a reason for that
you recall
Miss Bradley
so he may promote during jury selection
going to Great Lengths
to let you know that she does not have
to prove motive and she's right about
that the law doesn't require her to
prove motive
but you know it does require motive
a young man
to wake up one day
and decide that he's going to kill two
of his best friends
the best friends that he grew up with
best friends that he hangs out with
best friends who he lives with best
friends whose careers he was trying to
launch alongside his own
they have no reason
for why he would do this
because there is no reason
and if there's no reason it doesn't make
sense
and if after four years of Investigation
State comes and says hey he killed two
of his friends his best friends and
you're wondering why their answers are I
don't know
so you thought this was a good defense
opening I mean I dare him even say great
but what makes it so good in your eyes
well I think we all think it was pretty
strong first of all he talks about that
motive and know the prosecution doesn't
have to prove motive but it doesn't make
sense why would you kill your two best
friends the other issue is he said it
was a shoddy investigation in fact he
said it was fabricated not investigated
and he didn't just make that claim he
actually went into detail he said that
the Broward County Office had to
actually restart the entire
investigation saying that the Miramar
police didn't do their job that's a big
statement to make he's going to have to
back that up but he also said that they
didn't follow up on leads for years
there were people who were talking about
intimate details they didn't follow that
up they didn't get a search warrant to
search the house that Henry went into
there were so many things that they
failed to do and it was really very
specific and I think that that is going
to be something that's going to convince
that jury that he's not just making you
know false claims he's not just drawing
a wide brush he's actually backing up
with specifics yeah Bernardo to Terry's
point the defense attacked their
quote-unquote botched investigation and
I want to say they almost reframed the
jury's role in this case and what the
standard of proof is what did you make
of that strategy
I think the defense did a great job
especially in framing the role itself of
the jury and you have to think when it
comes to the defense they're telling
this jury like look it's not for me to
prove that my client is innocent it's
not for me to prove to you other things
it's for you to determine based on the
prosecution evidence whether they prove
their case Beyond a reasonable doubt
your job is to find reasonable doubt I
love this opening statement because he
didn't commit to a theory instead he
attacked the case of the prosecution and
told them what their job is you'll prove
your case Beyond A Reasonable Doubt I
don't have to say anything yeah they say
sometimes a great defense is an even
better offense and I think that's what
this opening statement really looked
like he really put it in the prosecutors
court so to speak to fight this case